>> Mark: WE ARE BACK NOW WITH
PART TWO OF THE SERIES IS
COLLEGE WORTH IT?
BECAUSE THE KEY TO SUCCESS IN
THIS COUNTRY, AND A DEGREE FROM
A BRAND-NAME UNIVERSITY IS A
VIRTUAL GUARANTEE OF WEALTH AND
POWER, AND WE BELIEVE THAT IT
IS, THEN ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS WE CAN ASK
ABOUT AMERICA IS THIS.
HOW EXACTLY DO YOU GET INTO A
PRESTIGIOUS UNIVERSITY?
WHAT ARE THE STANDARDS?
WELL, REMARKABLY, NOBODY REALLY
KNOWS THE ANSWER.
IT IS A BEWILDERING MYSTERY TO
MOST OF US.
IT IS A TREASURE MAP WITH THE
DIRECTIONS OF SPIRIT.
AND THAT IS NOT AN ACCIDENT.
COLLEGES CONSISTENTLY REFUSED TO
IT ADMIT HOW THEY ADMIT
STUDENTS.
SECRECY IS THE KEY TO THEIR
POWER, END.
BUT THERE ARE SOME FACTS
AVAILABLE, THANKS TO
WHISTLE-BLOWERS AND COLLEGE
ADMISSION OFFICES.
CIVIL RIGHTS SUIT FOLLOWED OVER
THE YEARS.
WE DO KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT
ADMISSION STANDARDS.
DESPITE WHAT YOU MAY HAVE HEARD,
HIGHER EDUCATION IS NOT
REALLY -- THEY ARE NOT A LOT OF
SLOW KIDS AT HARVARD, BUT THAT
DOES NOT MEAN THAT ALL OF THE
HARDEST WORKING APPLICANTS GET
IN.
OTHER FACTORS COME INTO PLAY.
THE FIRST AND PROBABLY LEAST
PUBLICIZED IS LEGACY ADMISSIONS.
YOU ARE MORE LIKELY TO GET INTO
A PRESTIGIOUS SCHOOL IF YOUR
PARENTS WENT THERE, MUCH MORE
LIKELY, IT TURNS OUT.
A2011 STUDY OF ELITE
UNIVERSITIES FOUND THAT THE
CHILDREN OF UNDERGRADUATE ALUMNI
WERE ON AVERAGE 45% MORE LIKELY
TO GET IN.
IN EARLIER STUDY FOUND THAT IT
WAS EQUIVALENT TO 160 POINTS ON
THE S.A.T.
THAT IS A MAJOR LEG UP.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT IT HELPS
WITH FUND-RAISING.
THEY DON'T LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
IT, BUT IT IS TRUE.
THE OTHER FACT THAT THEY DON'T
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT IS
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
IN REAL LIFE, THAT DECISION
MEANT NOTHING.
SKIN COLOR REMAINS AN ESSENTIAL
CONSIDERATION AT EVERY LEVEL OF
THE PROCESS.
THE AVERAGE ADMISSIONS OFFICE IS
EVERY BIT AS RACE CONSCIOUS IN
EVERY -- THE NUMBERS TELL THE
STORY.
THEY SHOW A HUGE DISCREPANCY
BETWEEN ACHIEVEMENT THAT
COLLEGES REQUIRE OF AFRICANS OF
DIFFERENT RACIAL GROUPS.
THIS IS TRUE AT THE
UNDERGRADUATE LEVEL IN THE
GRADUATE LEVEL.
NEW DATA FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICAN MEDICAL COLLEGES FOUND
THAT AFRICAN-AMERICAN STUDENTS
WITH LOW SCORES AND AVERAGE
GRADES HAD A 56% OF GETTING INTO
MED SCHOOL.
AT THE OTHER END, ASIAN STUDENTS
WITH THE EXACT SAME SCORES AND
GRADES HAD A 6% CHANCE OF
GETTING IN.
SO FACTS LIKE THIS HAVE SPURRED
LAWSUITS FROM INDIVIDUALS
ALLEGING DISCRIMINATION.
PROVING THAT THERE HAS BEEN
DISCRIMINATION.
DEFENDERS OF THE CURRENT SYSTEM
SAY THAT NOBODY IS BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AND THAT
RACE HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THESE NUMBERS.
OF COURSE, NO ONE ACTUALLY
BELIEVES THAT.
CONSIDER THIS EXAMPLE.
A RARE RACE NEUTRAL ADMISSIONS
POLICY, THE STUDENT BODY IS 43%
ASIAN IN 2013.
AT HARVARD, WHICH HAS A QUOTAS
AS IT ONCE DID AGAINST, EVEN AS
THE NUMBER OF ASIAN APPLICANTS
HAVE RISEN.
WHEN SKIN COLOR BECOMES A
CRITERION FOR ADMISSION, SOME
PEOPLE LOSE.
BUT WHO EXACTLY WINS?
YOU KNOW, NO ONE EVER ASKS THAT.
WE KNOW WHO IS SUPPOSED TO
BENEFIT.
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WAS DESIGNED
TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
AMERICANS WHOSE ANCESTORS HAD
BEEN DISCRIMINATED AGAINST.
PRIMARILY, THIS MEANT A BLACK
APPLICANTS.
YET, 50 YEARS AFTER AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION BEGAN, THE PERCENTAGE OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS ATTENDING
COLLEGES IT LOOKS TO BE
DROPPING.
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
SIMPLE.
IF FOREIGNERS ARE TAKING THEIR
PLACE.
UNDER THE RULES OF RACE
CONSCIOUS ADMISSION, THE SON OF
A NIGERIAN TYCOON MEETS THE SAME
STANDARDS AS THE SON OF A SINGLE
MOTHER FROM THE SOUTH SIDE OF
CHICAGO.
FOR DIVERSITY GOALS, THEY ARE
EXACTLY THE SAME, BUT YET THEY
ARE NOT THE SAME AT ALL.
ONE IS POOR, AMERICAN, AND
DISSENTED FROM PEOPLE BROUGHT TO
THIS COUNTRY BY FORCE.
YOU PROBABLY WANT TO HELP THOSE
KIDS.
THE OTHER IS A RICH FOREIGNER.
HE DOESN'T NEED YOUR HELP IT.
YET, WHO HAS A BETTER CHANCE OF
LEVERAGING DIVERSITY STANDARDS
TO GET INTO HARVARD?
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER, THE RICH
KID DOES.
HE GETS AN ADVANTAGE HE HASN'T
TURNED AND DOESN'T DESERVE.
AND THAT IS A WIN FOR HIM.
HARVARD WINS ALSO FOR BEING
INCLUSIVE.
MEANWHILE, THIS KID FROM THE
SOUTH SIDE OF CHICAGO DOES NOT
GO TO SCHOOL.
IT IS ACCELERATING AS
IMMIGRATION ACCELERATES.
THE 2007 STUDY FOUND THAT AMONG
BLACK STUDENTS IN THE TOP TO 28
AMERICAN UNIVERSITIES, IT WAS
DOUBLE THE REPRESENTATION IN THE
BAR POPULATION.
AT IVY LEAGUE SCHOOLS, STUDENTS
FROM IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
ACCOUNTED FOR NEARLY 41% OF
BLACK FRESHMEN.
AT HARVARD, A STUDY THREE YEARS
EARLIER FOUND THAT TWO-THIRDS OF
ALL BLACK UNDERGRADS WERE FROM
IMMIGRANT BACKGROUNDS.
THIS IS THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WAS DESIGNED
TO DO.
YET OVER TIME, THE DEFINITION OF
WHO IS ELIGIBLE HAS GOTTEN EVEN
FURTHER THAN WHERE IT BEGAN.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS NOW QUALIFY
FOR LOWER ADMISSION STANDARDS.
NOW IDENTIFYING AS HISPANIC
RATHER THAN WHITE, GIVES THEM
130 POINTS ON THE S.A.T.
SO THIS IS A HUGE ADVANTAGE FOR
NEWLY ARRIVED IMMIGRANTS OVER
AMERICANS.
WHY SHOULD THE DISSENTED OF
SPANISH CONQUISTADORS HAVE AN
ADVANTAGE OVER THE DESCENDANTS
OF IRISH INDENTURED WORKERS?
HOW IS IT FAIR?
OF COURSE, IT ISN'T FAIR.
THAT IS WHY IT IS NEVER
EXPLAINED OR DEFENDED.
AMERICANS LOSE IN THIS
ARRANGEMENT.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS GET SHAFTED
COMPLETELY IN FAVOR OF
FOREIGNERS WITH NO CONNECTION TO
THIS COUNTRY.
YET FEW COMPLAIN ABOUT IT
BECAUSE ALMOST NO ONE
UNDERSTANDS WHAT IS HAPPENING.
AND THAT IS WHY THE ADMISSIONS
PROCESS IS SECRET, SO THAT YOU
WANT CHALLENGED.
CHAIRMAN OF THE U.S. COMMISSION
ON CIVIL RIGHTS, SHE SPOKE WITH
US ABOUT ALL OF THIS JUST A
MOMENT AGO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS THE PURPOSE
OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION?
BECAUSE THE GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HAVE A CHANCE TO
ACHIEVE THE DIVERSITY THAT THEY
SAY THAT THEY WANT FOR THEIR
SCHOOLS.
FOR THE LONG-STANDING PRECEDENT
IS THAT THEY CAN USE AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION IF THERE ARE NO OTHER
MEANS TO ACHIEVE THAT DIVERSITY
TO BE ABLE TO SATISFY THIS.
>> Tucker: SO IT IS NOT AN
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS PAST WRONGS,
IT IS SIMPLY FOR THE SAKE OF
VARIETY.
>> WELL, IT STARTED AS AN
ATTEMPT TO MAKE UP FOR PAST
WRONGS, BUDGET SCHOOLS HAVE SAID
THAT WHAT THEY WANT TO DO IS
EDUCATE STUDENTS TO LIVE IN,
WORKING, BE PREPARED FOR AN
INCREASINGLY GLOBAL SOCIETY AND
ARE TO BE ABLE TO BE FULL
PARTICIPANTS IN THE WORLD THAT
THEY WILL ENTER.
SO ACHIEVING DIVERSITY IS ONE
WAY OF MAKING SURE THAT STUDENTS
ARE ABLE TO BE EDUCATED TO THAT
END.
>> Tucker: SO THIS HAS BEEN
DONE, YOU REDUCE IT TO GRADES
AND TEST SCORES.
IT STILL REMAINS TRUE THAT THE
CHINESE, PARTICULARLY, AND
KOREANS SCORE 500 POINTS HIGHER
THAN OTHER GROUPS WITH THE SAME
ADMISSIONS RATES.
>> SO HERE IS THE FLY IN YOUR
ANALYSIS.
YOU ARE REDUCING IT, THE
SCHOOLS, THE UNIVERSITIES HAVE A
FIRST AMENDMENT ACADEMIC
INTEREST IN SELECTING WHOM THEY
WANT TO EDUCATE AND HOW THEY
WANT TO EDUCATE.
AND WHAT THEY SAY --
>> Tucker: I AM JUST SAYING IT
IS DISCRIMINATION.
ANY OTHER GROUP WOULD BE TOTALLY
OUTRAGED.
>> WHAT THE COURT HAS SAID IS
THAT THAT IS NOT HOW WE ANALYZE
IT.
THAT IS NOT DISCRIMINATION.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHETHER THE
SCHOOLS ANALYZING --
>> Tucker: I AM AWARE OF WHAT
THE COURT SAYS.
I JUST DON'T THINK IT MAKES A
TON OF SENSE.
DO YOU THINK -- PART OF THE
PURPOSE OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, I